Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. And can you then impute a sinful deed to babes who on their mother's bosoms bleed? Was then more vice in fallen Lisbon found than Paris, where voluptuous joys abound? Was less debauchery to London known, where opulence luxurious holds the throne. That is, I think, a rather good English translation of Voltaire's poem on the Lisbon disaster, which he wrote in December 1755, one month after an earthquake on the 1st of November, which was All Saints Day, had levelled Lisbon, reducing about 85% of the city to ruins, killing perhaps
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你能把罪恶归咎于母亲胸前流血的婴儿吗？难道说沦陷的里斯本比巴黎有更多的罪恶？巴黎可是充斥着纵欲的欢乐。伦敦的放荡难道少吗？那里奢侈和富贵稳坐王座。我觉得，这段话把伏尔泰关于里斯本灾难的诗翻译得相当不错。他写于1755年12月，也就是11月1日（诸圣节）发生的那场地震的一个月后。那场地震几乎夷平了里斯本，将这座城市大约85%的面积化为废墟，可能夺去了
some 50,000 people. And Voltaire would return to the same question of how was it that such a disaster could happen? Were the philosophical explanations for why a good God could have permitted it to happen, were they justifiable? Even more famous work, Condede, which he published four years after that in 1759. And one of the reasons, Dominic, why the Lisbon earthquake, which we will come to, was so upsetting for people, not just in Portugal, but across the whole of Europe, was that Lisbon at that point was a famously beautiful and opulent capital, because this country that at the end of our previous episode, we had left as a kingdom that had been absorbed into the broader fabric of the kingdom of Spain, by the middle of the 18th century had not only regained its independence, but had really regained quite a lot of its mojo. It was importing vast quantities of gold, of diamonds,
大约5万人的生命。伏尔泰将再次回到那个问题：这样一场灾难怎么会发生？关于为什么仁慈的上帝会允许它发生，那些哲学解释是合理的吗？还有他更著名的作品《老实人》，他在那场灾难四年后的1759年出版了这部作品。多米尼克，里斯本大地震——我们待会儿会讲到——之所以让人们感到如此心烦意乱，不仅是在葡萄牙，而是在整个欧洲，原因之一就是当时的里斯本是一个出了名的美丽而富庶的首都。因为在上集结束时，我们留下的那个葡萄牙王国，曾被并入西班牙王国的更广阔版图之中，但在18世纪中叶，它不仅重获独立，而且真正恢复了相当大的一部分活力。它进口了大量的黄金、钻石，
and it seemed that Portugal was back. So before we come to the great earthquake of Lisbon, we should go back and look at how it is that Portugal manages to kind of re-emerge as an independent state. So, Tom, yes, we ended the last episode with you very tantalizingly promising us the First World War, by which I don't imagine you mean the real First World War. You mean a previous First World War. The First World War is the Fourth World War. This is the proper First World War. But before we get into the First World War, let's just quickly set the scene. Because Portugal, in our previous episode, we talked about the golden age of exploration and discovery
似乎葡萄牙又回来了。因此，在我们谈到里斯本大地震之前，我们应该回过头来看看葡萄牙是如何重新作为一个独立国家崛起的。汤姆，是的，上一集结束时，你非常诱人地向我们承诺了第一次世界大战，我猜你指的不是真正的第一次世界大战。你指的是之前的第一次世界大战。第一次世界大战是第四次世界大战。这才是真正的第一次世界大战。但在我们进入第一次世界大战之前，让我们先快速布置一下背景。因为在上一集里，我们谈到了葡萄牙的大航海时代和探索黄金时代
and so on, Vasco de Gama and whatnot. And we ended, as you say, in 1580. Portugal has been taken over by Philip II, the King of Spain, very famous as the architect of the Armada. But, Tom, a Portuguese listener to the rest is history, called Pedro Geraldes from Porto, has alerted me to something that we in Britain should be ashamed about. Do you know this? Ashamed?
等等，达伽马之流。正如你所说，我们在1580年结束了。葡萄牙被西班牙国王腓力二世吞并，他作为无敌舰队的策划者非常有名。但是，汤姆，一位来自波尔图的《历史其余部分》的葡萄牙听众佩德罗·热拉尔德斯（Pedro Geraldes）提醒我一件事，我们英国人应该为此感到羞耻。你知道这事吗？羞耻？
Ashamed. I know, ashamed. In 1589, the year after the Spanish Armada, Elizabeth I actually sent an expedition, an armada of her own, to Portugal to rescue the Portuguese from their Hispanic overlords. And it was led by the Earl of Essex, obviously a great friend of Elizabeth I, and Sir Francis Drake, a great bowls enthusiast. So led by two such lads, how could it possibly have gone wrong, Dominic? It went disastrously wrong, Tom. They took 20,000 men. Everything went wrong on the rendezvous. They turned turned up there wasn't an uprising as they thought there would be so basically they got distracted and they did that classic kind of crusader style thing of sacking some portuguese towns themselves right just sort of making a nuisance of themselves and annoying the locals so they've been sent to rescue the portuguese and
羞耻。我知道，羞耻。1589年，即西班牙无敌舰队被击败的次年，伊丽莎白一世居然派出一支远征队，也就是她自己的无敌舰队去葡萄牙，把葡萄牙人从他们的西班牙霸主手中拯救出来。这支队伍由埃塞克斯伯爵——显然是伊丽莎白一世的挚友——和弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士（一位狂热的草地滚球爱好者）率领。由这样两个活宝率领，事情怎么可能会搞砸呢，多米尼克？事情错得离谱，汤姆。他们带了两万人。会合时一切都出了岔子。他们赶到那里，发现并没有像他们想象的那样爆发起义，所以基本上他们分心了，做出了那种典型的十字军风格的事情，洗劫了一些葡萄牙城镇，对，就是四处招惹麻烦，惹恼当地人。他们本是被派去拯救葡萄牙人的，然后
then they turn on the portuguese because they don't know what else to do and then they just and then they went home and there are lots of people who've been waiting for them very excitedly, you know, sort of Portuguese patriots and Francis Drake and the Earl of Essex completely let them down. They're waiting, I think, in a place called Peniche. And ever since I'm told by Pedro Geraldo, and I looked it up and it's definitely true, the expression in Portuguese amigos de Peniche, friends from Peniche, means a traitor, a turncoat, a false friend, people who let you down. And that's us. I don't think that this is the kind of detail that we should be including in this podcast.
他们却反过来对付葡萄牙人，因为他们不知道还能做什么，然后他们就——然后他们就回家了。当时有很多人兴奋地等待着他们，你知道的，一些葡萄牙爱国者，而弗朗西斯·德雷克和埃塞克斯伯爵彻底让他们失望了。我记得他们在一个叫佩尼切（Peniche）的地方等待。佩德罗·热拉尔多告诉我，从那以后，我查了一下，这绝对是真的，葡萄牙语里的“佩尼切之友”（amigos de Peniche）这个词，意思就是叛徒、变节者、虚伪的朋友、让你失望的人。那就是我们。我认为这不应该是我们在播客中应该包含的细节。
Well. Why do you hate England, Dominic? Yeah. That is woke Tosh. That is woke Tosh. I think we should move straight on from that yes well the english will redeem themselves later in this podcast i promise the english will redeem themselves and the true villains if you're looking through portuguese lenses will prove to be not the english and actually not even the the spanish but the dutch the dutch are the absolute dogs in this podcast absolute dogs very poorly behaved so the first world war um is basically it's the dutch the dutch are absolute dogs in this podcast absolute dogs very poorly behaved so the
好吧。多米尼克，你为什么讨厌英格兰？是的。那是左翼空谈。那是左翼空谈。我想我们应该直接略过这个话题，是的，好吧，英国人会在本期播客的后面完成自我赎回，我保证英国人会自我赎回，如果你透过葡萄牙人的视角来看，真正的恶棍既不是英国人，甚至也不是西班牙人，而是荷兰人。荷兰人在这期播客里简直就是恶霸，绝对的恶霸，表现非常糟糕。所以第一次世界大战，嗯，基本上就是荷兰人，荷兰人是
first world war um is basically it's the dutch who are capitalist a maritime power as the portuguese had been very very interested in um taking over control of the spice trade um and they recognize that portugal having been absorbed into this kind of broader Spanish kingdom, is much less autonomous and therefore much less able to defend its trade links and its colonies. And so they move in. And as I say, the focus is really spice. And so the other name for this is called the Dutch-Portuguese War, but it's also known as the Spice War. But I think you can properly say this is the first world war in the sense that this is a war that spans the entire globe. So basically, it's a war fought over all the Portuguese colonies from Brazil, Angola, the East Indies, Malaysia.
资本主义海上强国，正如葡萄牙人曾经做的那样，非常非常热衷于接管对香料贸易的控制权；他们认识到，葡萄牙被并入这个更广阔的西班牙王国的版图后，其自主权大大降低，因此保卫其贸易路线和殖民地的能力也大大削弱。于是他们介入了。正如我所说，重点其实是香料。所以这件事的另一个名字叫作荷葡战争，但它也被称为香料战争。不过我认为你可以恰如其分地说这是第一次世界大战，因为这是一场横跨整个地球的战争。所以基本上，这是一场为争夺葡萄牙在巴西、安哥拉、东印度群岛、马来西亚等地的所有殖民地而进行的战争。
So an incredible conflict, and it rumbles on for the first six decades of the 17th century. Unbelievably long, isn't it? I mean, 60 years. And basically the Spanish, they don't pull their weight. And so this fuels a kind of escalating sense of resentment in Portugal that then combines with a sense that the Spanish economy and the Spanish state is really facing trouble. And so you start to get this kind of mood of insurrection in Portugal by the 1630s. Yeah. So I suppose if Portugal had been autonomous, completely autonomous, maybe some sort of alliance with England is traditional. I mean, despite the Peniche business. I think we would have done the right thing.
这是一场不可思议的冲突，一直持续到17世纪的前六十年。长得令人难以置信，不是吗？我是说，整整60年。基本上西班牙人并没有尽到责任。这助长了葡萄牙国内日益高涨的怨恨情绪，这种情绪随后与一种感觉结合在一起，即西班牙经济和西班牙国家确实面临着麻烦。因此，到17世纪30年代，你开始在葡萄牙感受到这种起义的情绪。是的。所以我想如果葡萄牙是自治的，完全自治的，也许与英格兰结盟是传统。我是说，尽管发生了佩尼切事件。我想我们会做正确的事。
I think, well, that's what, taken over Portugal's colonists for ourselves? No, we'd have stepped in and stood by our ally and fought off the Dutch. Maybe we would. I mean, the Spanish, I mean, it's not sort of tyranny under the Spanish, is it? Because as we said in the last podcast, Portugal maintains its own institutions. It's a union of the crowns rather than a union of countries but i think you're definitely right that by the mid-17th century a lot of portuguese just think this union with spain is is no good we want to be you know they're not helping us today and actually we've been dragged into this war with the dutch because of the association with spain so let's let's kick out
我想，嗯，那是把葡萄牙的殖民地据为己有吗？不，我们会介入并支持我们的盟友，击退荷兰人。也许我们会吧。我是说，西班牙人，我是说，在西班牙统治下并非那种暴政，对吧？因为正如我们在上一期播客中所说，葡萄牙保持着它自己的机构。这是一个王冠的联合，而不是国家的联合，但我认为你绝对说得对，到17世纪中叶，许多葡萄牙人只是觉得与西班牙的这种联合没有好处，我们想要成为——你知道的，他们今天不帮我们，实际上我们是因为与西班牙的联系才被拖入这场与荷兰的战争中的，所以让我们把西班牙人
the spanish there's a new spanish king Spanish king called Felipe IV who basically wants to, you know, it's the age of absolutism, and he wants to cement his power over Portugal. And he's got a kind of insane long chin, hasn't he? He does. Yeah. So the Portuguese elite have had enough. They launch an uprising on the 1st of December, 1640. There's a load of them called the Forty Conspirators,
赶出去吧。有一个新的西班牙国王，西班牙国王叫腓力四世，他基本上想要——你知道的，这是专制主义的时代，他想要巩固他对葡萄牙的权力。他有一种极其夸张的长下巴，对吧？确实如此。是的。所以葡萄牙精英阶层已经受够了。他们在1640年12月1日发动了一场起义，有一大群人被称为四十谋反者，
and they kill King Philip's Secretary of conspirators and they kill king philip's secretary of state and they imprison his cousin and they they launch this revolution and and this war that basically lasts 28 years and actually the the english stay out for most of it well because the portuguese are trying to get an alliance with france yeah which i think is very poor behavior yes because fr Because France is by far, you know, is by, is absolutely the preponderant power in Europe at this time.
他们杀死了腓力国王的国务秘书，囚禁了他的表弟，发动了这场革命和这场基本上持续了28年的战争。实际上，英国人在大部分时间里都置身事外，嗯，因为葡萄牙人正试图与法国结盟，是的，我认为这表现非常糟糕，是的，因为法兰西——因为法国绝对是——你知道的，是当时欧洲无可争议的绝对主导力量。
So the Portuguese hope that they can, they can have an alliance with, with, with France. And the person they want to marry off is the premier Duke of Portugal, as was John of Braganza. But he is an heir of, of Manuel I. And so he's a kind of living link with
所以葡萄牙人希望他们能够、能够与法国结盟。他们想要联姻的人是葡萄牙的第一公爵，也就是布拉干萨的约翰。但他也是曼努埃尔一世的后裔。因此，他是连接葡萄牙帝国伟大岁月的活生生的纽带。
the great days of the Portuguese empire. And so he's persuaded to become king. And actually a kind of fascinating churn behind this, we talked about Sebastian dying and vanishing in North Africa. And this sense that a kind of messianic nationalism is flaming through Portugal, this dream that Sebastian will come back. He doesn't, but John of Braganza does, or Jao of Braganza. And so he becomes the new king.
所以他被说服成为了国王。实际上，这背后有一种迷人的剧变，我们讨论过塞巴斯蒂安在北非的死亡和失踪。这种弥赛亚式的民族主义在葡萄牙燃烧的感觉，这种塞巴斯蒂安会回来的梦想。他没有回来，但布拉干萨的约翰回来了，或者说若昂·德·布拉干萨。于是他成为了新国王。
But of course, the great thing about him, for Anglo-Saxon, for English listeners, is his daughter marries Charles II, the Mary Monarch. So in 1660 in England and Scotland, Charles II is restored, and then the English do get involved, and we'll come to that in a second. But obviously Catherine of Braganza, I mean, she's not the best-treated wife, I think it's fair to say, in English royal history.
但当然，对于盎格鲁-撒克逊、英国听众来说，他最棒的一点是他的女儿嫁给了查理二世，即狂欢国王。因此，在1660年的英格兰和苏格兰，查理二世复辟了，然后英国人确实介入了，我们待会儿会讲到这一点。但显然布拉干萨的凯瑟琳——我是说，在英国王室历史上，她绝对不是待遇最好的妻子，我觉得这样说很公平。
She's famous because she, I don't think it's true that she introduces tea to England, because Samuel Pepys certainly was drinking tea before she pitched up. But she definitely popularizes, you know, she's a great tea drinker. Obviously, the Portuguese would be very interested in tea because of their links with the spice trade and all that sort of business. And she's keen on porcelain and cotton and other kind of innovations. So she's a sort of trendsetter. But here's the thing about Catherine of Braganza, Tom. Do you know what connects Catherine of Braganza and Donald J. Trump, former president of the United States?
她出名是因为她——我不认为她把茶引入英国是真的，因为塞缪尔·皮皮斯在她出现之前肯定已经在喝茶了。但她绝对推广了它，你知道的，她是一个狂热的饮茶者。显然，葡萄牙人会因为他们与香料贸易的联系和所有这类生意而对茶非常感兴趣。而且她喜欢瓷器、棉花和其他创新事物。所以她是个潮流引领者。但关于布拉干萨的凯瑟琳，有一点是这样的，汤姆。你知道是什么把布拉干萨的凯瑟琳和美国前总统唐纳德·J·特朗普联系在一起吗？
No. If I give you another clue and something that will delight you, they have this in common with Peter Parker, a.k.a. Spider-Man. Another subject I know you're very interested in. I have no idea. So Peter Parker, as our listeners will know, comes from Queens in New York. Queens is supposedly named after Catherine of Braganza. It was established in 1683 when she was the queen. Wow.
不知道。如果我给你另一个线索，一件会让你高兴的事，他们和彼得·帕克（又名蜘蛛侠）有这个共同点。这是另一个我知道你非常感兴趣的主题。我完全不知道。所以正如我们的听众所知，彼得·帕克来自纽约的皇后区。皇后区据说是以布拉干萨的凯瑟琳的名字命名的。它建立于1683年，当时她是王后。哇。
And in 1983, Tom, the Portuguese American friends of Queen Catherine wanted to set up a statue of Catherine of Braganza in Queens to celebrate their Portuguese heritage. And they enlisted the support of top, absolute top businessmen, top entrepreneurs. Somebody who knows more about business, statues, and Portuguese history than almost anybody. And that man was the future president, Donald Trump. And it will amaze you, Tom, to hear that after his involvement, the statue was never built.
而在1983年，汤姆，女王凯瑟琳的葡萄牙裔美国朋友们想在皇后区建立一座布拉干萨的凯瑟琳雕像，来庆祝他们的葡萄牙血统。他们争取到了顶级、绝对顶级的商人和企业家的支持。一个比几乎任何人都更了解商业、雕像和葡萄牙历史的人。那个人就是未来的总统唐纳德·特朗普。汤姆，你会感到震惊的是，在他参与之后，这座雕像最终从未建成。
Oh, why was that? Well, actually, it turned out that lots of local activists said Catherine of Braganza and the Portuguese were very involved in the slave trade. Well, that's indisputably true. It is indisputably true. And you shouldn't put up this statue, so it never was put up. So for people who were very keen on Mr. Trump's wall, this was a preview of what was to follow. Right.
哦，那是为什么呢？嗯，事实上，事实证明许多当地活动人士说布拉干萨的凯瑟琳和葡萄牙人大量参与了奴隶贸易。嗯，那是毋庸置疑的。这确实是毋庸置疑的。你们不应该竖起这座雕像，所以它最终没有被竖起来。所以对于那些非常热衷于特朗普先生的墙的人来说，这是接下来要发生的事情的预览。对吧。
Okay. I think those connections are slightly tenuous, but... No, no, no. Those are excellent connections. Those are fascinating connections. So anyway, Charles II sends an expedition to help his wife, his wife's family, and they comport themselves absolutely splendidly. They're all Cromwellian soldiers, aren't they? Yeah. They're part of the new model army that were left over from... From the previous regime. Yeah.
好吧。我认为这些联系有点牵强，但是……不，不，不。这些是极好的联系。这些是迷人的联系。不管怎样，查理二世派遣了一支远征队去帮助他的妻子、他妻子的家人，他们的表现绝对堪称出色。他们都是克伦威尔的士兵，对吧？是的。他们是新模范军的一部分，是从……前政权遗留下来的人。是的。
He sends them out. And do you know what Zhao's chief minister, the Count of Kastrel Mill, said about them? Did he praise them to the skies? He said, the English have done more than can be expected of them. And I believe there are no soldiers in the world like them. Well, that's splendid stuff. So the stain of 1589 is wiped away. And the alliance was polished up and blazed anew. And also another tremendous symbol of Anglo-Portuguese amity, she, as part of her dowry, she gives England what will become the city of Bombay, so Mumbai.
他把他们派了出去。你知道若昂的首席大臣卡斯特罗米尔伯爵（Count of Kastrel Mill）是怎么评价他们的吗？他把他们赞不绝口吗？他说，英国人做到了超乎预料的事情。而且我相信世界上没有比他们更好的士兵了。嗯，这真是太棒了。因此，1589年的耻辱被洗刷掉了。同盟被重新擦亮，焕发出新的光彩。这也是英葡友谊的另一个巨大象征，作为她嫁妆的一部分，她把将成为孟买（即孟买）的城市送给了英格兰。
That's very impressive. I didn't know that, Tom. Yeah, and so – Good for Catherine of Braganza. And so what you have there is a sense of an alliance between England, you know, the old alliance between England and Portugal, but is now starting to have global ramifications because it's shortly after this Anglo Portuguese alliance has been refurbished that essentially the First World War, a.k.a. the Spice War, the Dutch-Portuguese War, comes to an end. And Portugal has to give up quite a lot of its colonies. It loses the Cape of Good Hope. So that's, you know, hence the that's why you get Boers in South Africa rather than Portuguese settlers.
这太令人印象深刻了。我不知道这一点，汤姆。是的，而且——真为布拉干萨的凯瑟琳点赞。所以你在那里看到的是一种英国与英格兰之间的同盟感，你知道，英格兰和葡萄牙之间的老同盟，但现在它开始产生全球性的影响，因为就在这个英葡同盟被翻新后不久，第一次世界大战，也就是香料战争、荷葡战争，基本上就结束了。葡萄牙不得不放弃相当多的殖民地。它失去了好望角。所以这就是为什么南非会有布尔人而不是葡萄牙定居者的原因。
Malacca, you know, this great city that the Portuguese had won back in the early 16th century. Ceylon, so Sri Lanka, as is now, the Malabar Coast. So all that goes to the Dutch, but the Portuguese are able to keep, crucially, they're able to keep Macau, which remains a long-term colony, Goa, Angola, and the jewel in the Portuguese crown, Brazil. Yes.
马六甲，你知道的，这座葡萄牙人在16世纪初夺回的伟大城市。锡兰，也就是现在的斯里兰卡，马拉巴尔海岸。所有这些都归了荷兰人，但葡萄牙人能够保留——至关重要的是，他们能够保留澳门，它长期以来一直是殖民地，还有果阿、安哥拉，以及葡萄牙王冠上的明珠——巴西。是的。
So Brazil is a really interesting one, isn't it because brazil is um as it were colonized later than some other latin american countries uh and and much of it is is obviously it's not effectively going to be westernized if that's not i mean that's completely the wrong word but you know what i mean for for decades if not centuries um. And Brazil's population is tiny. So in 1700, there are still only 300,000 people in the huge expanse of Brazil. And the cities and towns are just, I mean, they're just fly-bitten, shabby kind of trading posts. Wouldn't the word, I don't know, would it be
所以巴西是一个非常有趣的地方，不是吗？因为巴西——就像人们说的那样——它的殖民化比其他一些拉丁美洲国家要晚一些，而且它的很大一部分显然不会有效地被西方化，如果这不是——我的意思是，这完全是个错误的词，但你明白我的意思——持续了几十年甚至几个世纪，嗯。而且巴西的人口非常少。因此，在1700年，在广袤无垠的巴西，仍然只有30万人。这里的城市和小镇只是——我的意思是，它们只是饱受苍蝇叮咬、破烂不堪的贸易站。难道不用这个词吗，我不知道，会不会是
Lusitanized, Portuguese? You know a lot more about this than me, but my understanding is that it's the discovery first of gold which happens what kind of 1700 yeah late 17th century yeah and then diamonds and that generates essentially the first gold rush and you get lots and lots of people from portugal suddenly thinking you know there's gold in their jungles or hills or whatever and and so they all go flooding across the atlantic and it's that process of settlement Lots of people from Portugal suddenly thinking, you know, there's gold in their jungles or hills or whatever. And so they all go flooding across the Atlantic.
“卢西塔尼亚化”或“葡萄牙化”？你对这方面的了解比我多得多，但我的理解是，首先是发现黄金，大约发生在什么时候，1700年，是的，17世纪末，是的，然后是钻石，这基本上引发了第一次淘金热，你会看到大量来自葡萄牙的人突然觉得——你知道的，他们的丛林或山丘里有黄金什么的，于是他们所有人蜂拥跨越大西洋，正是这个定居的过程——大量来自葡萄牙的人突然觉得，你知道的，他们的丛林或山丘里有黄金什么的。于是他们所有人都蜂拥跨越大西洋。
And it's that process of settlement that essentially introduces to Brazil. It kind of beds down Portuguese language, Catholicism, all those kind of cultural trends, all that kind of stuff. So that to this day, Brazil remains shaped by that huge influx. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. So the sugar, there's obviously the sugar plantations that have been there already. But you're right, there's the discovery of the gold, there's the gold mines in the state of Minas Gerais, which means general mines. And I said the population of Brazil was about 300,000 in 1700. In 100 years, it increases tenfold. So it's about 3 million by 1800, which gives you some,
正是这个定居过程，基本上将葡萄牙语引入了巴西。它巩固了葡萄牙语、天主教、所有这些文化潮流以及诸如此类的一切。以至于直到今天，巴西仍然受到这股巨大移民潮的塑造。是的，我认为这绝对是对的。所以，糖，那里显然已经有了甘蔗种植园。但你说得对，发现了黄金，在米纳斯吉拉斯州（意为总矿山）有金矿。我刚才说1700年巴西的人口大约是30万人。在100年里，它增长了十倍。所以在1800年大约有300万人，这给你提供了一些——
I mean, it's still quite small, but it gives you that some sense of the sort of, of the, of the trend, I suppose. And I think, I mean, you said at the beginning that Portugal got its mojo back. I mean, to some degree, obviously it has because it's independent and because all this gold is flowing in. But I think in other ways, Brazil is a great boon for the Portuguese and they come to rely on it. But it's also a kind of curse because they come to rely on it. So they can't kind of wean themselves off it. So the gold comes in, the sugar comes in,
我是说，它仍然相当小，但这让你对这种趋势有一些概念，我想。而且我认为——正如你在开始时所说，葡萄牙找回了它的 mojo（活力）。我的意思是，在某种程度上，它显然做到了，因为它是独立的，因为所有这些黄金都在流入。但在其他方面，我认为巴西对葡萄牙人来说是一大福音，他们开始依赖它。但这同时也是一种诅咒，因为他们开始依赖它。所以他们无法让自己戒掉它。因此，黄金涌入，糖涌入，
and they're making enormous profits from those things. But that means that they're not really building up their own domestic... And part of that is actually Britain. So they have signed a series of deals with the British, most famously the Methuen Treaty of 1703, that we talked about at one of our 12 Days of Christmas podcasts about port and about port wine.
他们从这些东西中获得巨额利润。但这意味著他们并没有真正建立起自己的国内……其中一部分其实是英国。因此，他们与英国人签署了一系列协议，其中最著名的是1703年的《梅休因条约》（Methuen Treaty），我们在我们的12天圣诞播客之一中讨论过关于波特酒的内容。
So that treaty basically, I mean, it's very much to Britain's advantage. Because basically the Portuguese don't put any tariffs on British cloth, and the British don't put any tariffs on Portuguese wine. But it's the cloth that is the boom. Yeah, it's the cloth that drives industry in the 18th century. Yeah. And wine, you know. Wine doesn't.
所以那个条约基本上——我的意思是，这对英国非常有利。因为基本上葡萄牙不对英国的布料征收任何关税，英国也不对葡萄牙的酒征收任何关税。但布料才是繁荣的根源。是的，布料推动了18世纪的工业发展。是的。而酒，你知道的。酒则没有。
And wine doesn't, exactly. So, I mean, Portugal, there um about three million people in portugal by the mid-18th century but it's very very agricultural um there's only two cities worthy of the name really lisbon and and porto which is and porto is dominated by the sort of the export and import trade with britain so there's a sense i think in the mid-18th century that the image that portugal had had 100 or 200 years before as one of the great shapers of globalization has kind of begun to fade by the mid 18th century. There's a sense of, I think, of growing backwardness. I mean, isn't there also a problem that the Portuguese royal family are entitled to a fifth of the gold that comes in?
而酒则没有，没错。所以，我的意思是，葡萄牙——到18世纪中叶，葡萄牙大约有300万人口，但它非常非常农业化，嗯，真正配得上城市称号的只有两个：里斯本和波尔图。波尔图由与英国的进出口贸易主导。所以我想在18世纪中叶有一种感觉，即葡萄牙在100或200年前作为全球化伟大塑造者之一的形象，到18世纪中叶已经开始褪色。我认为有一种日益落后的感觉。我的意思是，难道还有一个问题是，葡萄牙王室有权获得流入黄金的五分之一吗？
So it absolutely embeds colossal inequalities um and then on top of that you have i suppose you know so many people are going across to brazil that you're starting to lose a kind of working population in portugal i suppose there's a bit of a drain yeah and then actually i mean when you read about um the english settlers british settlers in portugal and we've been talking about this wonderful alliance and be very sentimental about it but but essentially when you read about it it it's pretty it's a kind of neo-colonialism isn't it yes because they come to be known as the factory uh the english trading community in lisbon and they have all these rights that are felt by many portuguese to be humiliating because the British are Protestant.
所以这绝对根深蒂固地造成了巨大的不平等，除此之外，我想——你知道的，这么多人前往巴西，以至于你开始失去葡萄牙国内的劳动人口，我想这有点像是一种人才流失。是的，而且实际上——我的意思是，当你阅读关于——英国定居者、英国人在葡萄牙的定居者时，我们一直在谈论这个精彩的同盟，并且对此充满感伤，但——但本质上，当你阅读相关资料时，这是一种相当典型的新殖民主义，不是吗？是的，因为他们被称为“工厂”，即里斯本的英国贸易社群，他们拥有许多被许多葡萄牙人视为羞辱的特权，因为英国人是新教徒。
And so they are a kind of standing offence to everything that the Inquisition represents, which is still going strong at this point. So I think maybe saying that Portugal has got its mojo back was the wrong way. But it's a kind of classic example, I suppose, of the way in which people talk about empire, overseas possessions being a kind of curse. Yeah, it's a very complicated picture, isn't it? Because on the one hand, I think it's reminiscent of countries like Argentina. So on the one hand, the Portuguese, there are people who resent the English and who resent their sort of sense of colonial, neocolonial dependency. And of course, at the same time, they admire the English. They see the English as the most modern, the most
因此，他们对宗教裁判所代表的一切构成了持续的冒犯，而宗教裁判所在当时仍然盛行。所以我想说葡萄牙找回了它的活力可能是错的。但我想这是一种典型的例子，说明人们如何谈论帝国，海外领地如何成为一种诅咒。是的，这是一幅非常复杂的画面，不是吗？一方面，我认为这让人想起阿根廷这样的国家。一方面，葡萄牙人中有些人怨恨英国人，怨恨他们那种殖民、新殖民主义的依附感。当然，与此同时，他们又崇拜英国人。他们把英国人看作是最现代、最先进的典范。
advanced and a sort of a model. And the classic example of somebody like that is a guy who's best known as the Marquês de Pombal. So he's the defining Portuguese statesman of the mid-18th century. And we're going to come back now eventually to Voltaire and his earthquake. So the Marquês de Pombal is born Sebastião José de Carvalho e Melo, I think it is. And he's born in 1699. He's the son of a nobleman. He studies at the great Portuguese University of Coimbra,
而这样的人的典型代表就是那个最著名的庞巴尔侯爵。他因此成为18世纪中叶最具决定性的葡萄牙政治家。我们现在最终要回到伏尔泰和他的地震。所以庞巴尔侯爵出生时叫塞巴斯蒂安·若泽·德·卡瓦略-梅洛（Sebastião José de Carvalho e Melo），我想是这个名字。他出生于1699年。他是一个贵族的儿子。他在伟大的葡萄牙科英布拉大学学习，
the great kind of medieval foundation, basically the only university in Portugal at that time. He elopes with a noblewoman. Isn't she Austrian? Yes, she's the niece of a Portuguese count. And they run off and get married. But he's appointed as ambassador to Britain. And actually, he's in Britain for seven years,
那是一个伟大的中世纪基金会，基本上是当时葡萄牙唯一的大学。他与一位女贵族私奔了。她不是奥地利人吗？是的，她是葡萄牙一位伯爵的侄女。他们私奔并结了婚。但他被任命为驻英国大使。实际上，他在英国待了七年，
and he's a fellow of the Royal Society. And he's really interested. He sort of travels around looking at British industry and British science and all these things. And he has this great vision of a modernized, sort of anglicized, I suppose. But also a kind of enlightenment. He's a kind of militant enlightenment figure, kind of quite radical and quite brutal. So he comes back and he becomes first minister doesn't he um yeah and he launches this really very brutal attack on
他是皇家学会的会员。他非常感兴趣。他四处旅行，考察英国的工业、英国的科学和所有这些事情。他有一个宏伟的愿景，要建立一个现代化的、某种程度上英格化的愿景。但也有一种启蒙运动的色彩。他是一个激进的启蒙运动人物，相当激进且相当残酷。所以他回来后成为了首相，不是吗？嗯，是的，他对
the nobility so um the the greatest nobleman in in portugal the duke of averro has his palace destroyed um and then very cool behavior he he sows the Duke's garden with salt, which is very Assyrian behavior. Yes. And then there's this unfortunate Marquess, the Marquess of Tavora, who is literally broken on the wheel. And then his wife has their children executed in front of her. And other members of the nobility are in prison for up to 20 years. So, I mean, this is kind of an assault on the nobility comparable to what would happen in the French Revolution. And then there's an attack on the church.
贵族阶层发动了一场非常残酷的袭击。所以——葡萄牙最伟大的贵族阿维罗公爵的宫殿被摧毁了，然后是非常冷酷的行为，他在公爵的花园里撒了盐，这是非常亚述式的行为。是的。然后还有这个不幸的侯爵，塔沃拉侯爵，他被活活绑在车轮上处死。然后他的妻子被迫眼睁睁地看着他们的孩子在她面前被处决。其他贵族成员被关押长达20年之久。所以，我的意思是，这是一次对贵族的打击，堪比法国大革命中将要发生的事情。然后是对教会的攻击。
So he presides over the expulsion of the Jesuits, who were very much the kind of, you know, the cutting edge of the Catholic Church. He brings science and mathematics into the curriculum at Coimbra. So basically, he tries to rein in the kind of the Inquisition and effectively abolishes it. And he abolishes the racial discrimination that had previously existed between Jews who'd been forcibly converted. Because he's aware, I think, that the expulsion of the Jews, which happened in the 17th century, 16th and 17th century, had been hugely to the disadvantage of Portugal. So and they'd all gone to settle in Amsterdam. So the most famous descendant of Portuguese Jews who settled in Amsterdam is Spinoza, the great philosopher. Yeah. So he's outlawing that.
所以他主持驱逐了耶稣会士，他们曾非常像是天主教教会的先锋。他将科学和数学引入了科英布拉大学的课程。所以基本上，他试图勒住宗教裁判所的缰绳，并有效地废除了它。他废除了此前在被迫改宗的犹太人之间存在的种族歧视。因为我想他意识到，发生在17世纪（16和17世纪）的驱逐犹太人事件对葡萄牙极为不利。所以——他们都去阿姆斯特丹定居了。因此，定居阿姆斯特丹的葡萄牙犹太人中最著名的后裔是伟大哲学家斯宾诺莎。是的。所以他在取缔这种做法。
So he's freeing the Jews from their disabilities and he's not doing this because he's a liberal. He's doing with a fair measure of brutality but what of course what he is not doing is abolishing slavery in the colonies where i mean it's on an enormous scale isn't it it's on a scale that dwarfs the the plantations in the the caribbean or in north america yeah you're right to bring this up actually tom uh because it's so little known i think in the anglo-saxon world where i mean the endless sort of conversations that we have about slavery and and the involvement of britain the united states and the slave trade and so on um but one thing we actually as you as you rightly say we completely miss is that the the portuguese ship i mean nobody's exactly sure of the number, but it's between four and five million, probably, slaves to the New World. And to put that into context, the Portuguese ship to Brazil, probably 10 times as many African slaves as are ever shipped to the United States of America.
所以他正在解放犹太人，恢复他们的权利，他这样做并不是因为他是一个自由主义者。他带着相当程度的残酷手段这样做，但当然他没有做的是废除殖民地的奴隶制——在那里，我的意思是，这是一种惊人的规模，不是吗？其规模之大，让加勒比地区或北海的种植园都相形见绌。北美，是的，你把这个提出来是对的，汤姆，因为在盎格鲁-撒克逊世界，这鲜为人知。我的意思是，我们无休止地谈论奴隶制，以及英国、美国参与奴隶贸易等等，但正如你所说，我们完全漏掉的一件事是，葡萄牙人运送到新世界的奴隶——虽然没有人确切知道数字，但在四百万到五百万之间。为了放在一个背景下对比，葡萄牙运往巴西的非洲奴隶数量，可能是运往美利坚合众国的十倍还多。
I mean, an astonishing figure. And I don't, I mean, maybe I'm wrong about this. We have quite a few Portuguese listeners. I'd be interested to hear from them how much this is discussed and debated. I mean, whether it's simply taken for granted and it's, you know, they have, as it were, come to terms with it or whether they've even had the conversation, the arguments, the endless sort of arguments that people have in Britain about it. And do they flagellate themselves about it?
我的意思是，这是一个惊人的数字。而且我不知道——也许在这方面我错了。我们有相当多的葡萄牙听众。我很想听听他们的意见，这个话题在他们当中被讨论和争辩了多少？我的意思是，它是被视为理所当然的，他们是否已经——怎么说呢——与它达成和解，或者他们甚至是否进行过这样的对话、争论，类似于英国人对它进行的无休止的争论？他们是否为此感到深深的自责？
Or do they just say, well, it was all in the past? I don't know. But obviously slavery is the single most important thing in shaping modern Brazil. And the legacy of it is still there in Brazil's racial politics today. So, yeah, it's a fascinating story and one not often told. But anyway, the Marcus de Pombal, I mean mean he's a whatever you you think of in individual policies he is i think it's fair to say isn't it tom by and large he is a remarkable man impressive
还是他们只是说，这一切都已经是过去式了？我不知道。但显然奴隶制是塑造现代巴西最重大的事情，其遗产至今仍存在于巴西的种族政治中。所以，是的，这是一个迷人的故事，却不常被讲述。无论如何，庞巴尔侯爵——无论你对他的个人政策作何评价，我认为可以公平地说，汤姆，大体上他是一个卓越的人，令人印象深刻。
i would say um but as you said right at the beginning coming right in the middle of his kind of tenure is that colossal sat one literally seism seismic disaster of the Lisbon earthquake, which, you know, it's not just an earthquake. It's All Saints Day. Tsunami, isn't it, as well? It's an earthquake, a tsunami, and then a firestorm, which destroys the great majority of buildings in the city. It's a firestorm, isn't it?
我想说的是，嗯，正如你在开始时所说，正当他执政中期的时候，发生了那场巨大的、字面意义上堪称地震级的灾难——里斯本大地震。你知道，这不仅仅是一场地震。这是诸圣节。还有海啸，对吧？这是一场地震、海啸，接着是一场火风暴，摧毁了这座城市绝大多数的建筑物。这是一场火风暴，对吧？
Because it's All Saints Day. And so everyone has gone to church and they've lit candles. And when the earthquake hits, everyone's in church, they'll get crushed beneath the churches, the candles blaze and the whole of Lisbon burns down. And it's that that particularly kind of raises eyebrows among those who are religious and among the philosophes, those who are sceptical. So that's where Voltaire is coming in. How could God allow this to happen? Because at at the time you know there's a real sense of enlightenment optimism isn't it the sort of um you know everything is for the best it's leibniz
因为这是诸圣节。所以每个人都去了教堂，点燃了蜡烛。当地震袭来时，每个人都在教堂里，他们将被压在坍塌的教堂下面，蜡烛燃烧，整个里斯本付之一炬。正是这一点，特别让那些笃信宗教的人和那些哲学家、那些怀疑论者感到大跌眼镜。这就是伏尔泰登场的地方。上帝怎么能允许这种事发生呢？因为在当时，你知道，有一种真正的启蒙运动乐观主义，不是吗？那种“一切都是为了最好”的观点，是莱布尼茨的观点——
is that leibniz yeah everything orders for the best in this best of possible worlds yeah so in condit his you know voltaire's famous kind of satire on that kind of philosophical optimism, it's exemplified by the figure of Pangloss, who is supposedly the greatest philosopher in the Holy Roman Empire. And he accompanies Condede and they get kind of involved in the, um, in, in the earthquake, Pangloss kind of surveying the rubble and the fire and the, the death and people screaming beneath the kind of shattered fabric of all these churches. And he says, ah, it's all,
那是莱布尼茨吗？是的，“在这个所有可能的世界中，一切都是最好的”——是的。因此，在《老实人》中，伏尔泰对这种哲学乐观主义进行了著名的讽刺，其典型代表就是庞斯格罗（Pangloss）这个人物，他据说是神圣罗马帝国最伟大的哲学家。他陪着老实人，他们卷入了这场地震中。庞斯格罗环视着废墟、大火、死亡，以及在所有这些破碎的教堂废墟下尖叫的人们，他说：“啊，这一切——”
you know, this is all for the best. Um, if this didn't happen, there'd be a terrible volcano explode somewhere else. Um, and he, Pangloss says this to a member of the inquisition and they get arrested,
你知道的，“这一切都是为了最好。如果这没有发生，其他地方就会爆发可怕的火山。”庞斯格罗对宗教裁判所的一名成员这样说，他们随即被捕，
uh, accused of heresy. Um, Condi gets whipped. Pangloss says this to a member of the Inquisition and they get arrested, accused of heresy. Condede gets whipped. Pangloss gets hanged. Condede is just about to be hanged himself when there's another earthquake and he manages to escape. And it's a very, very brutal satire on this kind of notion that everything is all for the best, the best of all possible worlds.
被指控为异端。老实人挨了鞭打，庞斯格罗对宗教裁判所的一员这样说，他们被捕并被控异端。老实人挨了鞭打，庞斯格罗被绞死。老实人正要被绞死时，发生了另一次地震，他设法逃脱了。这是对“一切都是最好的，所有可能的世界中最好的”这种观念非常、非常残酷的讽刺。
I mean, the interesting thing is that the Marcus de Pombal, he doesn't lose his Enlightenment optimism. He uses the earthquake as an opportunity to rebuild Lisbon on very Enlightenment sort of optimistic principles. Never let a crisis go to waste. No, he has this famous, apparently famous in Portugal anyway, this famous line where people are sort of, everyone's weeping and wailing and saying, what should we do? And he says, bury the dead and heal the living. he says it in exactly that very impressive way well he hangs a lot of people as well they put gallows up on the hills yeah he hangs all the looters but then he rebuilds the city so if you've been to lisbon and we haven't really talked that much about lisbon in these podcasts but lisbon i think is an absolutely spectacularly beautiful
有趣的是，庞巴尔侯爵并没有失去他的启蒙运动乐观主义。他利用这场地震的机会，根据非常启蒙运动的乐观主义原则重建了里斯本。绝不浪费任何一场危机。不，他有一句名言——在葡萄牙无论如何挺出名的——当人们都在哭泣哀号并问“我们该怎么办？”时，他说了这句话：“埋葬死者，医治生者。”他正是以那种非常令人印象深刻的方式说出这句话的。好吧，他也绞死了很多人，他们在山丘上竖起了绞架，是的，他绞死了所有趁火打劫的人，然后他重建了这座城市。所以如果你去过里斯本——我们在这些播客中并没有过多讨论里斯本，但我认为里斯本绝对是一座壮丽美丽且风格独特的城市。一方面，你有城堡和阿尔法玛的摩尔人宫廷，那是一个杂乱无章、几乎像北非一样的巷弄迷宫；而在另一方面，你有拜罗阿尔托（Bairro Alto），另一侧的高地，如今是一个非常时髦的街区，有酒吧、精品店之类的东西。在它们之间，你有一条山谷，而那正是被海啸和火风暴完全摧毁的地方。所以你在上一集中说过，我们——你知道，达伽马和他的帮派，我们对他们的了解其实不如我们应有的那么多，这大概是因为所有的记录都在火风暴中被摧毁了。
and stylish city and you've got the sort of on the one hand you've got the castle and the kind of moorish court of the alfama and it's all a hickledy-pickledy kind of almost north african kind of warren of alleys and then on the other hand side you've got the byro alto the the other high town on the other side um today very trendy kind of neighborhood with bars and boutiques and stuff and in between them you have this kind of valley and that was what was completely destroyed by the by the tsunami and the firestorm so you were saying in the previous episode that we all you know vasco de gama and his gang that we don't really know as much about them as we should and that's presumably
是的，我认为很多记录都被摧毁了。我的意思是，有许多关于提香、鲁本斯等大师的画作和其他艺术品被毁的故事。所以其中很大一部分被摧毁了，但庞巴尔将之转化——现在它被称为下城（Baixa），如果你去那里，那是一个网格状的布局，壮丽优美，非常优雅，闪闪发光的马赛克人行道通向水滨，这堪比爱丁堡或任何伟大的启蒙运动规划项目。正因为这与城市的其余部分形成了鲜明的对比，才让它显得更加令人印象深刻和震撼。
because everything all the records got destroyed in the firestorm yeah i think a lot of the records were destroyed i mean there were and there were all the stories of paintings and things that were destroyed as well by tishan and rubens and people like that so a lot of that is destroyed but pombal turns that i mean it's now it's called the baisha and if you go there it is a grid it is spectacularly beautiful very elegant these kind of gleaming mosaic pavements leading down to the waterfront and it's comparable to edin Edinburgh or any great enlightenment kind of project. And because it's such a contrast with the rest of the city, it makes it all the more impressive and all the more striking.
但庞巴尔垮台了，不是吗？是的。新女王多娜·玛丽亚上台了，她非常虔诚。当然，正如你所说，他并不是反教权主义者——也许这个词不对，但他对天主教特权的怀疑是显而易见的。她对此深恶痛绝。她基本上在成为女王后不久就把他赶下了台。不仅如此，我在我的博德利图书馆深度研究中在网上看到，她拥有历史上最早的限制令之一，上面写着——基本上他不准靠近她二十英里以内，如果她去参观靠近他住所的庄园，他必须离开自己的房子进行疏散。
But Pompadour falls, doesn't he? He does. There's a new queen, Donna Maria, and she's very religious. And of course, you were saying he's not anti-clerical is the wrong word, maybe, but he's certainly very sceptical of the Catholic Church's kind of privileges. And she can't stand that. And she basically boots him out within moments of becoming queen. But she also, I read online in my very close Bodleian research, she had one of history's first restraining orders it says i can come um so that basically he wasn't allowed within 20 miles of her presence and if she visited her estates which were near his he had to leave his house evacuate them yeah yeah but then she goes
是的，但后来她疯了，不是吗？有点像乔治三世那样——所以她有同一个医生，叫什么名字？弗朗西斯·威利医生。他基本上过来后说：“我对她无能为力。这是一种痴呆症，或者没人知道，可能是卟啉症，可能是躁郁症，我的意思是，当时的人们将她形容为基本上是一个宗教狂人。”所以这有点象征着葡萄牙经济和国际地位的不断下滑，并将在革命战争和拿破仑崛起期间跌至绝对谷底。我认为我们应该在休息后讨论这个话题。当我们这样做时，我们将进入半岛战争的戏剧性事件以及王室从葡萄牙的非凡撤离。所以我们稍后会回来。一会儿见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《历史其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻的固定栏目，
mad doesn't she um a bit like she does third uh so she has the same doctor um what's his name doctor uh francis willis and he basically comes over and says i can do nothing for her it's a kind of dementia or no one knows could be porphyria could be manic depression could be i mean people at the time describe her as basically a religious maniac so this is a this is kind of um emblematic of an escalating decline in Portugal's economy, international standing that will hit absolute rock bottom with the Revolutionary Wars and the rise to power of Napoleon, which I think we should come to after a break. So when we do that, we will come to the drama of the Peninsular War and the extraordinary evacuation from Portugal
疯了，不是吗？嗯，有点像她做第三个……所以她有同一个医生，叫什么来着？弗朗西斯·威利斯医生，他基本上过来后说我无能为力，这是一种痴呆症，或者没人知道，可能是紫质症，可能是躁郁症，我的意思是当时的人们把她形容为基本上是个宗教狂热分子，所以这有点象征着葡萄牙经济和国际地位不断恶化的衰退，这将在革命战争和拿破仑掌权时达到绝对的谷底，我想我们休息之后再谈这个。所以当我们这样做的时候，我们将迎来半岛战争的戏剧性事件以及从葡萄牙的非凡撤离
of the Royal Family. So we will come back with that. See you in a minute. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
王室的撤离。所以我们将带着这个回来。一会见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻的固定节目，
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to the second half of the third episode in our epic history of Portugal. And Dominic, we have reached the early 19th century. And Dominic, Portugal, not in a good way, very much economically a bit on its uppers, but also, more importantly, menaced by Napoleon
评论，以及少许的娱乐圈八卦。而在我们的问答环节，我们会拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、获取额外单集以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们宏大的葡萄牙历史第三集的下半部分。多米尼克，我们已经来到了19世纪初。多米尼克，葡萄牙的处境不太妙，经济状况大不如前，但更重要的是，它受到了拿破仑的威胁。
because, of course, Portugal is the ally of Britain. Napoleon is trying to kick the British out of the continent. So in a way, Lisbon and Oporto are the two kind of entry points that the Royal Navy still have into what is otherwise fortress Europe. So a huge crisis for portugal because they basically have to choose between france and britain and offending either one is is obviously you know a nightmare yeah they're so they're stuck really the portuguese it's actually an issue so in our fourth podcast when we get to world war ii it's it's a not dissimilar position actually
因为，当然，葡萄牙是英国的盟友。拿破仑正试图把英国人赶出欧洲大陆。因此在某种程度上，里斯本和波尔图是皇家海军通往其他方面已成为“欧洲堡垒”的仅有的两个入口。所以对葡萄牙来说这是一场巨大的危机，因为他们基本上必须在法国和英国之间做出选择，而得罪任何一方显然都是一场噩梦。是的，所以他们真的陷入了困境，葡萄牙人。其实这跟我们在第四期播客中讲到第二次世界大战时的情景非常相似。
that they they that they're they have this alliance with Britain, but they feel they are trapped by a sort of belligerent, sort of menacing neighbour, in this case, France. But I mean, it's worth saying, isn't it, that the reason why the alliance with Britain is so important is that Portugal's links to Brazil are absolutely crucial to it, and the Royal Navy can guarantee those links but obviously the british don't have sufficient land forces perhaps to keep portugal defendable from from the french army so so actually napoleon has multiple i mean napoleon very much not a friend certainly not a friend of the rest of this rest is history presenter and i think i think
当时他们与英国结盟，但他们感到自己被一个好战的、具有威胁性的邻国（在这里是法国）所困。但我的意思是，值得一提的是，与英国结盟之所以如此重要，是因为葡萄牙与巴西的联系对其至关重要，而皇家海军可以保证这些联系。但显然后来英国没有足够的地面部队来保护葡萄牙免受法国军队的攻击。所以实际上，拿破仑有很多——我的意思是，拿破仑绝对算不上朋友，当然不是《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）节目主持人的朋友，而且我觉得。
you're a bit unsound on napoleon but we will um i have my suspicions but we'll we'll come back to that when we do we do a big napoleon series i mean god how many episodes are we doing on a page um we did the french revolution in one so maybe half well we did napoleon in egypt didn't we so we we have we have started on that we did so napoleon has already when the time the crisis really comes to Portugal, Napoleon has actually already basically threatened and browbeaten the Portuguese once with his ally Spain. So the Spanish had led armies into the north and south of Portugal. They had taken the town of Olivenza. Napoleon had basically compelled the Portuguese to pay him an indemnity
你在拿破仑的看法上有点不够稳妥，不过我们会……我有我的怀疑，但当我们做一个大型拿破仑系列节目时，我们会再回过头来谈这个。我的意思是，天哪，我们在拿破仑身上要花多少集？我们用了一集来讲法国大革命，所以也许一半吧。哦，我们做过《拿破仑在埃及》，对吧？所以我们已经开始了。是的，拿破仑当时已经——当危机真正降临到葡萄牙时，拿破仑实际上已经利用他的盟友西班牙威胁并恐吓过葡萄牙一次了。因此西班牙军队曾攻入葡萄牙北部和南部。他们占领了奥利文萨镇。拿破仑基本上强迫葡萄牙向他支付赔偿金。
of 20 million francs and close some of its ports to the British. But he comes back for more, and we're in 1807, and his ambassador basically tells – so Dona Maria, because she's gone mad, is kind of out of the picture. So her son, Dom João, is basically the regent. And he's a bit ineffectual, isn't he? He is. He's sort of melancholy and, yeah, sort of full of that self-doubt. And he's not a great leader of men, I think it's fair to say.
2000万法郎，并关闭了其面向英国的部分港口。但他卷土重来，时间来到了1807年，他的大使基本上转告了——唐娜·玛丽亚因为已经疯了，所以基本上淡出了权力中心。因此她的儿子唐·若昂基本上成了摄政王。他有点无能，对吧？是的。他有点忧郁，而且，是的，充满了自我怀疑。而且他不是一个伟大的领袖，我觉得这样说挺公允的。
And the French basically say to him, you have to recall your ambassador from London, break diplomatic relations with Britain, close the ports of British ships, arrest all the Brits in Lisbon, confiscate their property, and you've got weeks to make up your mind. And Dom Zhao, he's a great character. He lives in this palace in Mafra, and he's got this huge library, and he's surrounded by all these books and monks,
法国人基本上对他说，你必须召回你在伦敦的大使，与英国断绝外交关系，对英国船只关闭港口，逮捕里斯本所有的英国人，没收他们的财产，你只有几周时间来做决定。而唐·若昂，他是一个很有特色的人物。他住在马夫拉的这座宫殿里，里面有巨大的图书馆，周围全都是书和僧侣。
and the library is infested with insects. So the monks maintain a sort of menagerie, if that's the word, of bats, which they use to deal with the insects in Dom Jarre's library. So he's like Batman sitting in the middle of Wayne Manor, a very miserable figure. And he asks the British what he should do, and the British basically say, what you have to do is this we will take you to brazil you know you will flee we'll take your entire royal household to brazil but you must open all the ports in brazil to british goods
而且图书馆里虫害泛滥。所以僧侣们养了一群——如果可以这么说的话——蝙蝠，用来对付唐·若昂图书馆里的昆虫。所以他就像坐在韦恩庄园正中间的蝙蝠侠一样，是一个非常悲惨的人物。他问英国人他该怎么做，英国人基本上说，你必须这么做：我们会把你带到巴西去，你知道的，你会逃跑，我们会把你的整个王室带到巴西，但你必须向英国商品开放巴西的所有港口。
so basically allow us to control the trade um with brazil um and he doesn't like that so he plays for time the british actually i mean again we i'm not convinced that the british come out of this quite as well as we might like to think because they basically say listen if you don't do this um we will consider that an act of war and we will bombard Lisbon ourselves. So you have to choose between us and the French and you have to choose us or we'll attack you. Yeah. I mean, so my rosy sense of this of this alliance is I'm finding it rather upsetting having to having to face how perfidious Albion. But now we do come out well, Tom, because we send a splendid fellow to Lisbon. So he's called Sir Sidney Smith, the Lion of the Sea.
所以基本上允许我们控制与巴西的贸易，而他不喜欢这样，所以他在拖延时间。英国人其实——我的意思是，再次声明，我不确信英国人在这件事上的表现能像我们愿意认为的那样好，因为他们基本上说，听着，如果你不这么做，我们将认为这是战争行为，我们将亲自轰炸里斯本。所以你必须在我们和法国之间做出选择，你必须选择我们，否则我们就会攻击你。是的。我的意思是，我对这个同盟的美好感觉——我发现不得不面对阿尔比恩（英国）的背信弃义是如此令人沮丧。不过现在我们的表现确实不错，汤姆，因为我们派了一个了不起的家伙去里斯本。他叫悉尼·史密斯爵士，海中雄狮。
Friend of the show, because he's the one who he was in our episode on Napoleon in Egypt. So remind me, Tom, what was he doing in that? Siege of Acre. Yes. And he sees Napoleon off and Napoleon says, this is the man who cost me my destiny so in another um he's a very i mean i know you won't like this because we mentioned in previous podcasts that you don't like this you don't like rope you don't like naval technology and you don't like the novels of patrick o'brien but sir sydney smith strikes me as a very jack aubrey figure because like jack aubrey he's's imprisoned he's imprisoned by the French
节目的老朋友了，因为他在我们关于拿破仑在埃及的那集里出现过。所以提醒我一下，汤姆，他在那集里干了什么？阿克围城战。是的。他击退了拿破仑，拿破仑说，这就是夺走我命运的人。所以在另一个——他是一个非常——我知道你不会喜欢这个，因为我们在之前的播客中提到过你不喜欢这个，你不喜欢绳索（译者注：此处对应原文rope，可能为语音识别错误或特定梗），你不喜欢海军技术，你也不喜欢帕特里克·奥布莱恩的小说，但悉尼·史密斯爵士给我的感觉是一个非常典型的杰克·奥布瑞式的人物，因为就像杰克·奥布瑞一样，他被囚禁了，他被法国人囚禁了。
for two years for being a spy which as if you would know if you had read Patrick O'Brien's books Tom you would know it's not fun it's not fun but it's also but it but it's very rousing it makes you proud to be British that somebody would you know hold out in such a way and then come back and rescue the Portuguese royal family
两年，罪名是间谍，如果你读过帕特里克·奥布莱恩的书，汤姆，你就会知道这可不好玩，这可不好玩，但这也很振奋人心，它会让你为身为英国人而骄傲，竟然有人能以这种方式坚守，然后回来拯救葡萄牙王室。
which is precisely the line of the sea right so yeah November 1807 the French are basically moving in on Portugal and then come back and rescue the Portuguese royal family, which is precisely what happened. And be called the Lion of the Sea. Right. So November 1807, the French are basically moving in on Portugal. The Portuguese royal family make up their minds, all right, we'll go. And there's this amazing scene. So there's a brilliant book, actually. I mean, it sounds like a very obscure subject,
这正是海中雄狮所做的，对吧？所以1807年11月，法国人基本上正在向葡萄牙挺进，然后回来拯救葡萄牙王室，这正是发生的事情。被称为海中雄狮。好吧。所以1807年11月，法国人基本上正在向葡萄牙挺进。葡萄牙王室下定决心，好吧，我们走。这里有一个令人惊叹的场景。事实上有一本非常棒的书。我的意思是，这听说起来是一个非常冷门的题材，
but honestly, it's a brilliant book. It's a book about Brazil by Eloisa Starling and Lillia Moritz-Schwartz, which I wrote about in the Sunday Times a few years ago, called Brazil, A Biography. And they have this amazing set piece where they basically say, you know, it's like a scene from Dante's Inferno, all these huge mobs of people kind of swarming down to the docks in Lisbon. I mean, just thousands upon thousands of people preparing for the voyage to Brazil.
但老实说，这是一本极好的书。这是一本由埃洛伊萨·斯塔林和莉莉娅·莫里茨·施瓦茨合著的关于巴西的书，我几年前在《星期日泰晤士报》上写过它，书名叫《巴西：一部传记》。书中有这样一个精彩的场景，他们基本上说，这就像但丁《地狱》中的一幕，成群结队的人流涌向里斯本的码头。我的意思是，成千上万的人在为前往巴西的航程做准备。
So kind of maids and servants and courtiers and noblemen, basically anybody who is anybody. And Donna Maria, right? And Donna Maria, who's been, because she's, of course, mad. She's screaming and sobbing because she thinks she's been kidnapped yeah yes so she's been taken down in her carriage it's an absolutely risible kind of chaotic scene i mean as they say in their book it's not just a case of the royal family it's the families of ministers of counselors of their ability of the court of civil servants it's the entire
女佣、仆人、朝臣和贵族，基本上只要算得上人物的都在其中。还有唐娜·玛丽亚，对吧？还有唐娜·玛丽亚，她一直以来——因为她当然已经疯了。她在尖叫、哭泣，因为她以为自己被绑架了。是的，她是被抬着坐进马车里的。这是一个绝对荒谬、混乱的场景。正如他们在书中所说的那样，这不仅仅是王室成员的问题，还有部长、顾问、贵族、宫廷、公务员的家属，整个行政机器都是如此。
administrative machine the government offices the secretariats the law courts the archives the treasure the government employees do they take an orchestra like um they take everything like the last emperor of mexico i think they take dinner dinner services and they take wardrobes and they take because they're basically moving the entire in their minds they are moving portugal you know the how the royal, the sort of symbol of Portugal, across the Atlantic to Brazil to about 15,000 people. They did what the British royal family didn't do in the Second World War. Exactly. Because there was kind of talk of them going to Canada, wasn't there?
政府办公室、秘书处、法庭、档案室、金库、政府雇员，他们甚至带了一个管弦乐队，就像——他们带了一切，就像墨西哥的最后一个皇帝一样，我想。他们带了餐具、衣柜，因为他们基本上是在搬迁整个——在他们心目中，他们是在把葡萄牙，把葡萄牙的象征跨越大西洋搬到巴西去，大约有15,000人。他们做了英国王室在二战中没有做的事。完全没错。因为当时甚至有关于他们要去加拿大的讨论，对吧？
But I don't think if they had gone to Canada. I like to think, now maybe this is me just flattering myself and my country, but I find it hard to believe that in 1940 there would have been 15,000 people shouting. Well, they'd have to take all the footmen and the horses. Would they have taken the footmen? I mean, maybe they would. I don't know. I kind of imagine they'd have done it more discreetly in a more tweedy way. Do you know what I think?
但我认为如果他们去了加拿大。我愿意相信——也许这只是我在美化自己和我的国家——但我很难相信在1940年会有一万五千人高喊……好吧，他们得带上所有的随从和马匹。他们会带上随从吗？我的意思是，也许他们会吧。我不知道。我总觉得他们会用一种更低调、更具英国乡村风格的方式来做这件事。你知道我是怎么想的吗？
George VI? Yeah, probably. But anyway, they get on these ships um the british are escorting them there are no beds uh the crew is too small um what's it so this is from that brazilian biography it says um the water all the water was reserved for drinking and even the ships that conducted the prince regent the queen and the princes were disgraceful and stank like pig's thighs the lady's hair became infested by fleas obliging them to shave their heads thus the journey dragged on monotonous interminable apart from the distractions of watching the sails being hoisted and singing
乔治六世？是的，很可能是。不管怎样，他们登上了这些船，英国人护送他们前往，那里没有床，船员太少了。内容是什么呢？——这是那本巴西传记里说的，它说……所有的水都被留作饮用，甚至连运送摄政王、王后和王子们的船只也是糟糕透顶，散发着猪大腿般的恶臭。女士们的头发里长满了跳蚤，迫使她们剃光了头，于是航程在单调、漫长中拖延着，除了看升起船帆和在日落及月夜下伴着吉他唱歌外，无事可做，只能打牌。
to guitars at sunset and on moonlit nights there was nothing to do but play cards and they're just doing this for weeks when they arrive in bra, all the ladies of the court are bald. They must be, or shaven-headed anyway. Wow. I mean, what a spectacle. But then the spectacle is incredible because they get off. They've never been. They have never been. No European royal has ever been to the New World.
他们就这样度过了好几个星期，当他们到达巴西时，宫廷里所有的女士都是光头的。她们肯定是的，或者至少剃了光头。哇。我的意思是，真是一场奇观。但随后的景象简直不可思议，因为他们上岸了。他们从未去过。从来没有哪个欧洲王室去过新大陆。
So they get off the ships and they arrive in Salvador, which is then, I think, effectively the capital of Brazil. And that's the great slave port, isn't it? It's a great slave port. So it is this huge slave market. It's basically a glorified slave market. And the get-off is filthy. There are people crowding around.
所以他们下了船，到达了萨尔瓦多，当时那里基本上是巴西的首都。那是个著名的奴隶港，对吧？这是一个主要的奴隶港。所以这是一个巨大的奴隶市场。它基本上就是一个美化了的奴隶市场。下船的地方很脏。周围挤满了人。
There's rubbish in the streets. It's muddy. There are strange plants and animals and all this sort of stuff and you know for them it's and it is the the culture shock of culture shocks and meanwhile because they've opened brazil as part of the deal to british manufacturers other ships are unloading these bizarre products that the the british are forcing the Brazilians. So ice skates, ladies' shark fin corsets, warming pans, thick woolen blankets, and mathematical instruments. So all these things that are being made in, I don't know, Barnsley or something, are being
街上有垃圾。到处是泥泞。有奇异的植物和动物以及诸如此类的东西，你知道，对他们来说——这绝对是文化冲击中的文化冲击。与此同时，由于他们将巴西作为协议的一部分向英国制造商开放，其他船只正在卸下这些英国强加给巴西人的奇特产品。比如冰鞋、女士鲨鱼骨胸衣、暖床盘、厚羊毛毯和数学仪器。所有这些在，我不知道，巴恩斯利或其他什么地方制造的东西，都被。
shipped over and the Brazilians are being forced to buy them. Oh, brilliant. A woolen blanket. Just what I want. Yeah. Okay. So that's a scene in Brazil. Meanwhile, back in Portugal, high drama,
运了过来，巴西人被迫买下它们。哦，太棒了。一条羊毛毯。正合我意。好吧。这就是巴西的场景。与此同时，在葡萄牙，高潮迭起，
because of course the French are moving against Portugal and the British need to defend what is their bridgehead. Yeah, exactly. And so they send one of their top generals, don't they? Sir Arthur Wellesley, who... Do you know, is this his first appearance on The Rest Is History? I think it might be, because of course, Sir Arthur Wilsley will go on to become the Duke of Wellington. But this is really where... He's been a general in India, hasn't he? And done great
因为法国人正在对葡萄牙采取军事行动，而英国人需要保卫他们的桥头堡。是的，完全正确。所以他们派出了他们最顶尖的将军之一，对吧？阿瑟·韦尔斯利爵士，他……你知道吗，这是他在《历史其余部分》中的首次登场吗？我觉得很可能是，因为阿瑟·韦尔斯利爵士后来将成为威灵顿公爵。但这也是真正……他之前曾在印度担任过将军，对吧？并在那里立下了丰功伟绩。但这是他第一次在欧洲大陆指挥作战。而且他干得很好。他击败了法国人，他签署了《辛特拉公约》，法国人撤出了葡萄牙，然后他们又卷土重来——典型的背信弃义的法国行为，韦尔斯利再次击败了他们。正是在那之后他被封为贵族，因为在1809年第二次把法国人赶出去而被封为威灵顿公爵，我想是这样的。所以我们现在可以叫他威灵顿了。我们可以这么叫。所以他入侵了西班牙，对吧？他在塔拉韦拉赢得了这场伟大的胜利，这——我的意思是，离马德里很近，我想，但随后他意识到自己寡不敌众，于是他撤退了。
stuff there. But this is really his first experience of campaigning on the continent. And he does very well. So he defeats the French uh he he signs the convention of sintra the french evacuate portugal uh they then invade again typical perfidious french behavior uh again wellesley defeats them that's when he is ennobled that's what he's made the duke of wellington for kicking the french out for a second time in 1809 i think it is so we can start calling him wellington now we can so so he invades spain doesn't he he wins this great victory at talavera which is uh i mean almost near madrid i think uh but then he realizes that he's massively outnumbered and so he he he withdraws and he
并且他把重点——与其在西班牙对法国发动进攻，不如全力确保里斯本的安全，因为他知道法国人会再次发动进攻。于是就有了著名的托雷斯韦德拉斯防线，它们是在1809到1810年期间修建的。我想大概有152座堡垒，它们的修建——我的意思是，葡萄牙人基本上是被强征去修建这些堡垒的，这完全是焦土政策。所以实际上葡萄牙变成了一片饱受战争创伤的废墟。嗯，这就相当于比利时，对吧？绝对是的。我的意思是，你知道，大炮在地面上炸出了弹坑之类的事情。而且它们的修建规模极其宏大，
focuses uh rather than kind of taking the attack to the french in spain on absolutely securing lisbon because he knows that the French are going to make another attack and so these are the famous lines of Torres Vedras which are built over the course of 1809 to 10. 152 forts I think it is and they're built using I mean the Portuguese are basically press ganged into building these forts and it's real scorched earth policy so actually Portugal is a is a sort of battle scarred wasteland well it's the belgium yeah absolutely it is yeah i mean you know sort of cannons are blasted kind of craters out of the earth and all that sort of thing and they're built on a huge scale aren't
对吧？我的意思是托雷斯韦德拉斯防线，如果你看那些照片，我的意思是这些堡垒相当大，我的意思是它们是非常结实的堡垒。谁知道呢？我想随着战争的进行，葡萄牙人变得越来越仇法。我的意思是，正如你所料，你基本上在三年内被侵略了三次。所以，当然，那种认为法国人可能是来自旧政权的共和解放者的想法已经烟消云散了，我想在西班牙也是如此。是的，就像在西班牙一样。所以半岛战争——我的意思是，很多主要的行动都发生在西班牙，这是一个非常混乱且血腥的故事。我们应该。
they i mean the lines of torres verdas if you look at the pictures that i mean the forts are they're pretty sizable i mean mean, they're pretty chunky forts. I mean, who knows? The Portuguese, I think, become increasingly francophobic as the war goes on. I mean, as you would expect, you've been invaded three times in three years, basically. So, of course, any sense of sort of the French might be there. Republican liberators from the old regime has pretty much evaporated, I would say in spain as well yeah as it does in spain as well so the peninsula war i mean a lot of the main sort of major action takes place in spain and it's a very confused and sort of bloody story well we should
我们应该做一集关于这个的节目，不是吗？但我的意思是，从葡萄牙的角度来看，是的，法国人最后一次试图占领里斯本。那是马塞纳率领的，他是最好的元帅之一，拿破仑对他评价极高。但他无法突破。因此托雷斯韦德拉斯防线坚守住了。基本上这确保了葡萄牙能够逃脱被法国征服的命运，并确保了英国人能够守住桥头堡，这至关重要。所以这些都在进行中。因此，你现在有了葡萄牙和巴西，不再是葡萄牙作为宗主国而巴西作为殖民地，我的意思是，巴西开始基本上成为这个联合王国的中心。
do we should do an episode on that shouldn't we but i mean from the point of view of this of this um of portugal yeah there is one last attempt by the French to capture Lisbon. And that's under basically one of the best marshals there is, Messina, whose Napoleon rates very, very highly. But he can't break through. And so the lines of Torres de Dres hold. And basically that ensures that Portugal will escape French conquest and it ensures that the British will maintain their bridgehead, which is absolutely crucial. So that's all going on. So you've now got Portugal and Brazil, rather than Portugal being the colonial power and Brazil a colony, I mean, Brazil is starting to basically become the kind of the center of this United Kingdom.
确实如此。这是一个如此非凡的故事。而且没有——我想不出世界上任何地方有类似的对比。我的意思是，也许听众们能想出一个例子，其中宗主国基本上搬到了殖民地，而殖民地最终几乎变成了宗主国。所以基本上发生的情况是，葡萄牙和巴西，他们的总人口在19世纪之交时，我猜大致相当。但王室已经搬到了巴西。当与拿破仑的战争结束后，唐·若昂并没有直接回到葡萄牙。他留在了巴西的里约热内卢，并提升了巴西的地位。
It is. It's such an extraordinary story. And there's no, I can't think of a comparison anywhere in the world. I mean, maybe listeners will be able to think of one where the metropole basically moves to the colony and that ends up almost becoming the metropole. So what's basically happened, Portugal and Brazil, their populations are, I guess, roughly equivalent in the turn of the 19th century. But the royal family have moved to Brazil. And when the war with Napoleon is over, Dom João, he doesn't come straight back to Portugal. He stays in Brazil, in Rio, and he elevates Brazil.
所以这个王国现在被称为葡萄牙、巴西和阿尔加维联合王国。那么阿尔加维是什么？我以为只有一个阿尔加维呢。嗯，我想可能有一些岛屿被包含在阿尔加维里面了。那么什么是阿尔加维？我以为只有一个。嗯，我想可能有一些岛屿被包含在阿尔加维里面。这有点像那个，多个西西里，两西西里。对，好吧。
So the kingdom is now called the United Kingdom of Portugal, Brazil, and the Algarves. So what are the Algarves? I thought there was just one. Well, I think maybe some islands are included in the Algarves. So what are the Algarves? I thought there was just one. Well, I think maybe some islands are included in the Algarves. It's a bit like the, the multiple Sicily, the two Sicilies. Right. Okay.
我觉得用复数听起来总是更好听。确实如此。对。难道不是吗？我的意思是，对。你知道，
I think it always sounds better if you have a plural. Yes, it does. Yeah. Doesn't it? I mean, yeah. You know,
我曾经有一本——一本儿童历史书，一本非常老式的儿童历史书，上面说有多个不列颠（Britons），这就是为什么它被称为大不列颠（Great Britain）。好吧，所以当时有三个不列颠。你知道它们是什么吗？加拿大。对，所以它是。
I once had a, um, a children's history, a very old fashioned children's history book, which said that there were multiple Britons, which is why I was called great Britain. Well, so there were three Britons. Do you know what they were um canada yeah so it was
不列颠、布列塔尼以及海外更广阔的不列颠。不管怎样，很受启发。汤姆，若昂不想回家，葡萄牙人——而且他不想脱掉外套，对吧？他拒绝脱掉外套。这是一个非常重要的细节。他好像在一把叉子什么的上面把它撕破了。所以他的侍臣们不得不在他睡觉的时候去把它缝好。所以他显然没有完全掌控局面。是的，他的餐具抽屉里少了几把叉子，诸如此类。是的。
britain brittany and the wider britain beyond the seas very inspirational anyway um tom shout doesn't want to come home and the portuguese and he doesn't want to take his coat off, does he? He refuses to take his coat off. That's a very important point. He kind of rips it on a fork or something. And so his chamberlains have to go and sew it up while he's asleep. So he's clearly not entirely on top of things. Yeah, his several forks short of a cutlery drawer or whatever. Yeah.
是的。与此同时，在葡萄牙，葡萄牙人显然对王室去了巴西却不肯回家感到痛心疾首，而且他们也失去了自己在帝国中的地位。并且，你知道，拿破仑战争结束后出现了一场萧条。发生了粮食歉收。正如我们所知，我们以前谈论过19世纪初的气候状况，比如没有夏天的年份或者诸如此类的事情。他们的货币基本上在崩溃，高通胀。他们基本上说巴西人根本不在乎我们，什么都不给我们寄。而且这种骚动越来越激烈，这种自由主义的骚动，他们说王室应该回到葡萄牙，应该宣誓遵守一项宪法，这基本上将首先赋予自由主义精英更多的权力。这是19世纪自由主义宪政的一部分。但同时，我们也绝对希望明确一点：我们才是老大，而不是巴西人。国王归来。这就是他们。
Yeah. Meanwhile, in Portugal, so the Portuguese are obviously gutted that the royal family has gone to Brazil and won't come home, but also they've sort of lost their status in their own empire. And, you know, there's a sort of depression at the end of the Napoleonic Wars. There were harvest failures. You know, as we know, we've talked before about the sort of climactic conditions of the early
想要的。他们想要国王归来。你知道这其中有哪些重要人物吗？ Freemasonry（共济会）在其中扮演了非常重要的角色。所以……哦，他们总是不务正业。嗯，共济会组织在葡萄牙开明的上流社会和中产阶层中非常庞大。
19th century, sort of year without a summer or whatever it is and all this stuff. Their currency is in sort of meltdown, high inflation. They basically say the Brazilians don't care about us, they don't send us anything. And there's this increasing, increasing ferment, this sort of liberal ferment where they say that the royal family should come back to Portugal and they should swear a constitution that basically will, first of all, give sort of liberal elites more power. So part of that liberal constitutionalism of the 19th century. But also, we absolutely want it to be clear that we're the top dogs, not the Brazilians. The return of the king. That's what they Brazilians. The return of the king.
所以他们为此四处煽动。基本上他们要求若昂回来，他也确实在1821年4月回来了。依然穿着他的外套。他依然穿着他的外套。他心如死灰。他想留在巴西，因为基本上在巴西他一切都如愿以偿。
That's what they want. They want the return of the king. And you know the big people in this, so a very big thing in this is Freemasonry. So... Oh, they're always up to no good. Well, Masonic societies are very big among the sort of Portuguese enlightened sort of upper classes and middle classes.
如果他回到欧洲，那就是革命的发源地。欧洲是政治骚乱和动荡的发源地，而且，你知道的，他会被所有这些葡萄牙大人物摆布。他才不要那样。他据说是如此难过，以至于话都说不出来了。但在他失去说话能力之前，他对他的儿子佩德罗说，你留在巴西担任巴西的摄政王。基本上，如果他们叫你回来，
So they're agitating for all this. And basically they demand that Zhao comes back, which he does in April 1821. Still wearing his coat. He's still wearing his coat. He's absolutely gutted. He wanted to stay in Brazil because basically in Brazil he's got everything kind of as he wants it.
如果他们试图把巴西从你手中夺走，你应该宣布独立或者别的什么。我的意思是，他对此完全是公开的。若昂回来了。葡萄牙人逼迫他接受了这部新宪法。他必须宣誓效忠宪法。他的妻子拒绝了，所以她被剥夺了王室特权。但现在葡萄牙人得寸进尺，他们说，你的儿子还在巴西。他也必须回到葡萄牙。他担任巴西摄政王这档子事纯属胡扯。他必须废除这一切。巴西的共济会员实际上非常反对这一点。他们说，不，不，不。他们授予他“巴西守护者”的称号。
If he goes back to Europe, it's the home of revolution. Europe is the home of political ferment and turbulence. And, you know, he'll be pushed around by all these Portuguese bigwigs. He doesn't want that. He's so sad, apparently, that he can't speak. But before he's lost the ability to speak, he says to his son, Pedro, you stay in Brazil as regent in Brazil. And basically, if they tell you to come back,
多恩·佩德罗（唐·佩德罗）也是一个稍微有点无能的人。他受过非常好的教育，但每个人都说他无法集中注意力，总是跟别人有染，行为有些不端。这一切在1822年夏天接近尾声时达到了顶峰。葡萄牙人说（这绝对是最后通牒），佩德罗必须回到葡萄牙。不幸的是，佩德罗患有慢性腹泻。所以他的形象并不怎么光鲜亮丽。但尽管如此，他在频繁跑厕所的间隙，还是发表了这番激昂的演讲。冲向厕所。
if they try to take Brazil from you, you should declare independence or something. I mean, he's completely upfront about this. Jao comes back. The Portuguese browbeat him into this new constitution. He has to swear an oath of loyalty to the constitution. His wife refuses, so she's kind of stripped of her royal privileges. But now the Portuguese go further and they say, your son is still in Brazil. He needs to come back to Portugal as well. And this business of him being regent in Brazil is rubbish. He needs to scrap all that. The Brazilian masons actually are very anti this. And they say, no, no, no. they invest him in brazil with the title defender of
是的。他在演讲中说，独立还是死亡。而这一切——通常情况下，哦，汤姆，我不敢相信你在《历史其余部分》里做了音效，这是你的第一个音效。好吧，这简直就是全部。而我想做的是——所以他发表了演讲，他说“独立还是死亡”，我想所有的拉丁美洲人在宣布独立时都会这么说，我想这是法律规定，对吧？根据联合国公约，你必须说“独立还是死亡”，然后他们就获得了独立，因为当然葡萄牙人也没什么办法，他们无能为力。不，他们没有——不像他们拥有可以用来镇压巴西人的海军和陆军。英国人对此态度如何？因为假设他们的态度真的很重要，因为他们控制着使葡萄牙和巴西能够相互通信的航运路线。所以实际上英国人充当了调解人，英国人并不在乎是不是由葡萄牙人统治巴西。他们想做的是确保自己在这两个地方的商业主导地位。这样他们就可以卖出所有的羊毛毯。
brazil don pedro don pedro is a slightly useless man as well he's been very highly educated but he's everybody says he can't focus he's always having affairs with people he's sort of badly behaved um and it basically all comes to a head in the late summer of 1822 the portuguese say you know this is an absolute ultimatum. Pedro has to come back to Portugal. Pedro, unfortunately, has chronic diarrhea. So he's not cutting a very glamorous figure. But nevertheless, he gives this rousing speech in between sort of running to the loo. Rushing off to the toilet.
是的，胸衣和冰鞋。但有趣的是，对于那些认为英国人在今天的播客过程中表现并非总是那么高尚的人来说，英国人同意的一项交换条件——我的意思是，英国人基本上进行调解，他们说服葡萄牙人给予巴西独立，承认巴西独立——其中一个交换条件是，英国人（这正是鼎盛时期，我的意思是，英国的废奴主义，19世纪初），他们说，我们希望你们废除奴隶贩运。不一定是在巴西境内废除奴隶制，但要停止奴隶贸易。而巴西人用一种非常转弯抹角的方式。
Yeah. In which he says, independence or death. And and all this which is generally what oh tom i can't believe you did a sound effect on the your first sound effect on the rest of history well and it was everything and what i want to do uh so he gives the speech he says independence or death which i think that all latin american people say when they're declaring independence i think that's the law isn't it yeah by un convention you have to say independence or death which i think that all latin american people say when they're declaring independence i think that's the law isn't it yeah by un convention you have to say independence or death and they get independence because of course there's not really anything the portuguese they can't do anything no they haven't got it's not like they've got a navy and an army that they
他们算是同意了。所以在1831年，他们同意了一项法律，基本上规定当奴隶到达巴西时，他们将被视为自由人。而他们完全彻底地无视了它。所以这完全是个虚构和骗局。有没有一句著名的葡萄牙语总结了这一点？你在看笔记。你在超前阅读。有的。那就是 uma lei para o inglês ver，意思是“给英国人看的法律”，在巴西葡萄牙语中基本上意味着做表面文章。
can really use to crush the brazilians what's it what's the attitude of the british to this because presumably their attitude really matters because they control the shipping lanes that enable Portugal and Brazil to communicate with each other. So really the British act as mediators and the British don't care whether Portuguese run Brazil or not. What they want to do is to ensure their own commercial dominance in both places. So they can sell all their woolen blankets. Yes, corsets and ice skates. But interestingly, for people who think that the British have not always behaved with distinction in the course of today's podcast, one of the sort of quid pro quos
是的。事实上，直到1888年巴西才废除奴隶制。既然我知道我们时间不多了，我只想说这就是巴西。巴西现在从葡萄牙历史中消失了，因为它独立了。但是，汤姆，我们将重返巴西，这是一个其历史几乎完全不为人知的国家，当然在英国是这样，但在更广泛的英语世界可能也是如此。我们将重返巴西的命运，因为巴西显然成为了一个帝国。不仅在英国，在更广泛的英语世界也几乎完全不为人知，我们将重返巴西的命运，
for the British agreeing that they will – I mean, the British basically mediate and they persuade the Portuguese to give Brazil their independence, to recognise Brazilian independence. One of the quid pro quos is that the British, this is the heyday, really. I mean, abolitionism in Britain, the early 19th century. And they say, we want you to scrap slave trafficking. Not necessarily abolish slavery within Brazil, but stop the slave trade. And the Brazilians, in a sort of very roundabout way,
因为巴西显然在唐·佩德罗及其继承人的统治下变成了一个帝国。所以我们将在未来的播客中重返巴西帝国、巴西奴隶制的废除以及巴西帝国的覆灭，对吧？因为我们在秋天要做一些非常令人兴奋的播客。是的，我们有一个巨大的、非常令人兴奋的计划的一部分。
they kind of agree. So in 1831, they agreed to a law that says basically when slaves arrive in Brazil, they will be considered free. And they completely and utterly ignore it. So it's a complete fiction and a fraud. And is there a famous Portuguese phrase that sums this up? You're reading the notes. You're reading ahead. There is. It's uma lei para o inglês ver, a law for the British to see, which basically in Brazilian Portuguese means addressing it up.
一个庞大的、非常非常令人兴奋的计划的一部分，我们即将推出，我们会谈论它，这是绝密，除非你是王（指会员），你们已经知道了，但是，是的，这是我绝对期待的事情。好吧，我想我们应该——我们应该在这里停下来。我们现在为我们宏大的葡萄牙历史第四部分（也是最后一部分）做好了所有铺垫。绝对的高潮。我知道，多米尼克，这是你非常期待的一集，因为你是法多（Fado）音乐的超级粉丝，对吧？法多音乐。而汤姆要唱歌了。我会唱的。
Yeah. And actually, it's not until 1888 that slavery is abolished in Brazil. And since I know we're running out of time, so I will just say this is Brazil. Brazil now vanishes from Portuguese history because it's on its own. But, Tom, we will be returning to Brazil, which is a country whose history is almost entirely unknown, certainly in Britain, but probably in the English-speaking world more generally. We'll be returning to what happens to Brazil because Brazil obviously becomes an empire entirely unknown, certainly in Britain, but probably in the English-speaking world more generally, will be returning to what happens to Brazil,
那是法多。好吧，我可能会跟着哼唱。还有20世纪葡萄牙独裁者萨拉查这个非凡的人物。独裁者。是的，非常令人兴奋。非凡的人物。所以托尔金在他的《指环王》三部曲中只写了三部，汤姆，但我们更胜一筹，因为我们在这个伟大的系列中做了四部。
because Brazil obviously becomes an empire under Dom Pedro and his successors. So we'll be returning to the Brazilian empire and the abolition of slavery in Brazil and the downfall of the Brazilian empire in a future podcast, won't we? Because we're going to be doing some very exciting podcasts in the autumn. Yes, we've got part of a massive very exciting podcasts in the autumn yes we've got
四部曲。人们已经把它称为历史播客中的《指环王》了，对吧？是吗？他们这么叫吗？你听过别人这么叫吗？我确信他们有，我确信他们有。所以我们明天见。非常感谢大家的收听，请务必回来收听20世纪的葡萄牙。拜拜，阿迪达斯。再见。在 restishistorypod.com。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。
a mass part of a massive very very exciting plan that we've got coming that we will talk about top secret unless you're a wang they already know but uh yeah something i hope that definitely to look forward to okay so i think we should um we should stop at this point. And we have everything is set up now for the fourth and concluding part of our epic history of Portugal. The absolute climax. And I know, Dominic, this is an episode you've been hugely looking forward to because you are a huge Fado fan, aren't you? Fado music. And Tommy's going to be singing. I will be singing.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及少许娱乐圈八卦的固定去处。而在我们的问答环节，我们会拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、获取额外单集以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 rest is 本集节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
That's Fado. Well, I might hum along. And the extraordinary figure of Salazar, the 20th century Portuguese dictator. Dictator. Yes, it's very exciting. Extraordinary figure. So Tolkien only did three in his Lord of the Rings trilogy, Tom, but we have gone one better because we have done four in this mighty series.
这就是法多。好吧，我可能会跟着哼唱。还有20世纪葡萄牙独裁者萨拉查这位非凡的人物。独裁者。是的，这非常令人兴奋。非凡的人物。所以托尔金在他的《指环王》三部曲中只写了三个，汤姆，但我们更胜一筹，因为我们在这个伟大的系列中做了四个。
A tetralogy. Which people are already calling the Lord of the rings of history podcasts aren't they yeah are they calling that have you heard people calling them i'm sure they are i'm sure they are uh so we will we will see you tomorrow um thanks very much for listening uh and um do come back for portugal in the 20th century bye-bye adios Adios. at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
四部曲。人们已经在把这称为历史播客里的《指环王》了，不是吗？是的，他们这么叫吗？你听过人们这么叫吗？我确信他们有，我确信他们有。所以我们明天见，非常感谢大家的收听，请回来收听20世纪的葡萄牙。再见，阿迪奥斯。阿迪奥斯。在 restishistorypod.com。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的神秘面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的节目、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票，请前往... 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。